[Music]
a new documentary takes a unique look at
race in America the HBO film called one
thousand percent Me growing Up mixed
features interviews with 11 kids ages 7
to 16. it's directed and produced by W
Kamal Bell an emmy-winning host and
comedian that's just a couple of things
that he does he spoke with two of his
daughters and other kids in their San
Francisco Bay Area Community here's a
clip of him interviewing his
ten-year-old daughter Sammy as well as
11 year old miles and seven-year-old
smells take a look
when you look in the mirror what do you
see I like to think that mirrors don't
show everything like Amir showed the
outside of you but they can't tell like
the inside of you or how you identify
like just by the look of you
and if I ask you what ingredients
what are they
um ingredients are
family friends
happiness
thoughtfulness
[Music]
lots of emotion
black Asian
and love
and a llama and a corgi
Kamal Bell joins us right now good
morning how you doing I'm doing great
I'm here with y'all look at this I made
it up here how about that things have
been worse I love the uh sweater by the
way uh not all Mac and cheeses are
created equal I think that's true that
is true it's mahogany mommy's a black
woman-owned t-shirt company okay great
no doubt about it um so you have made
documentaries before uh but you don't
really interview children they can be
the most brutally honest creatures on
the planet yes what did you learn
you know making a doc about mixed kids I
have three mixed daughters in my house
you saw Sammy right there what I learned
is that this younger generation of mixed
kids don't think of themselves as being
like half this and half fat they think
of it as being like I'm 100 this and 100
fat they don't think of as being like
bifurcated or fractions they think of as
like more toppings on the pizza is that
where the 1 000 me comes from yeah miles
who we see in that clip earlier says I'm
100 African-American 100 Filipino and a
thousand percent a person and I love
that when he said it yeah that was
something that really stood out to me
this is the thing about all these
children number one they were all so
powerful also strong but one of the
conversations that really got to me was
Mila Mila was talking about uh being
biracial and you asked her about should
we be having these conversations about
race and what did she say uh she said I
said what do you some people say kids
can't handle these conversations so
absolutely you should teach kids about
race and racism because it's better to
learn that stuff early than it is to
learn when you're an adult and she said
it's better to teach them to them when
they're young yeah better than the thing
that got me in that scene she's sitting
in between her mom and her dad the look
on her dad's what's his name the dad's
name Brian Brian the way he was looking
at his daughter because it's not like he
was egging her on she was just speaking
she's 10 she was just speaking from her
heart about that no I mean a lot of this
is like you see the parents here there's
these proud parent moments where and I
say it at the end our job is to like set
these kids up and get out of the way in
that moment Brian was like I'm a good
dad
but the other thing you did was you said
some couple you also talked to a lot of
parents some parents talk about uh being
mixed race about the children they're
going to be raising ahead of time others
do not yeah how did you and your wife
navigate that conversation I mean me and
Melissa we've been together 20 years we
had Sammy like a like eight years into
our relationship so we had spent a lot
of time talking about race and racism
and we live in the Bay Area so we're
surrounded by mixed kids and we knew
that Samuel was going to have an
identity identity different than us so
we prepared Melissa learned how to do
black hair she took classes and went
online and did stuff so it was about
like understanding this kid was going to
be different than us and preparing for
it so we could envelop her I mean to
Gayle's Point not all parents take it on
in that way so having done this
documentary you haven't talked to
parents about it what is your advice
generally to parents out there
understand that having a mixed-race kid
means you're going to have a kid who has
an identity that is not related to you
so you should do everything you can to
support all sides of that kid's identity
I think some parents don't think about
that they just think I'm having my child
should they think about it I've think
they should because you find out a lot
of mix I've heard from a lot of mixed
race adults who felt like they were cut
off from a side of their race because
maybe that parent wasn't around and that
parent didn't push their culture so I
think a lot of mixed kids want to engage
with all sides of what their identity is
you had an older guy I think his name
was Roy he said I may be mixed but I'm
not mixed up yeah Roy I thought that was
such a great line but the other thing I
thought was interesting you took your
mom and Melissa's mom I don't know if
they get along they don't get along it
was a very interesting awkward I thought
awkward shot where they're sitting on
the couch your mom talks about race her
mom did not no they they are friendly
because they're grandmothers but they're
not friends and certainly Melissa's mom
is not having race conversations
regularly unless I'm around so it was
really the fact that Wilson's mom would
do that I understood she was doing it
for her granddaughters if this is
important for my granddaughters she's
like an ultimate Grandma I will sit here
and feed and lean into this awkward
conversation about race with my mom who
comes with her knives all this but I
thought it was powerful though though to
the dynamic between the two of them and
what they both shared yeah and it was
also I mean a lot of times in my work
there's things I do that are almost more
for me than for the film I wanted to
hear what that conversation would be and
I was really honored by the fact I
didn't think my mother-in-law would do
it but yeah yeah you've said on stage um
you've said in interviews time and time
again and you just said it right now it
just comes out naturally you lean in to
these awkward conversations what is it
about you that almost craves these
moments I don't know no better you know
I just I just I get curious about things
and so I'm curious about all sorts of
things yeah but conversations and things
people don't want to talk about I just
get excited about trying to figure out a
way to talk about but come out a lot of
people want to leave lean out of these
conversations and in schools today a lot
of parents organizations and then a lot
of school districts are saying you know
we're not going to talk about it as much
right what advice do you have based on
your experience with this documentary
about what schools should be doing a
good question when does it ever help to
not talk about a problem yeah when does
it ever help to not talk about things
and learn things uh I think this film we
were making at the same time there's the
anti-woke anti-crt stuff and it very
effortlessly addresses the fact that
kids can handle this information they
can talk about it and these kids have
the conflict in their DNA sometimes yeah
they want to they want it and they're
not overwhelmed by it it's it's not
about being less it's about being more
you know the other thing I liked I don't
know if it was deliberate it's only an
hour I actually think it should be
required viewing in all schools
certainly among mixed race but I think
all of us could benefit from it gives
you time to
digested conversation about it it's so
well done I can't say enough about that
but it was deliberately an hour yeah
because I'm a parent and I wanted it I
know how kids tap out unless something
exploding or magical so yeah I wanted I
wanted families to be able to watch it
and have the conversation that's great
we appreciate you give yourself a round
no doubt about it
even though some of your work might seem
self-serving it is serving us as a
nation and we appreciate you thank you
so much thank you very much all right do
you think this work is self-served well
he says it he said I thought I was
catching the straight to Gail but no no
self-serving in assistance oh come on
I'm trying to do my job halfway through
I got it but at first I was like hey
wait a minute
I was just trying to give you an
opportunity thank you clean it up
growing up you're welcome thank you it's
streaming now on HBO Max check it out